everyone knows that Michael sailor
Michael strategy they got a lot of
Bitcoin about 130 000 Bitcoin or so
approximately and now that the price of
Bitcoin has fallen down to around thirty
thousand dollars there's a lot of people
speculating what are they going to do
are they going to sell any of that
Bitcoin will they be forced to liquidate
any of it what would the ramifications
be if one of the large holders of
Bitcoin actually went ahead and sold now
of course we have an example of a large
order having to sell recently the Terra
ecosystem they had a liquidate almost 80
000 Bitcoin and bitcoin's price
definitely went down touched around
twenty six thousand dollars but
ultimately Bitcoin is resilient and
Bitcoin just stayed strong and we
continue to see all the underlying
fundamentals continue to get stronger
everything from hashary to nodes on the
lightning Network the number of holders
and also those with at least 300 in
their Bitcoin wallet addresses so
ultimately that big seller of the Terra
ecosystem didn't have nearly as big of
an impact as many people had previously
thought so going back to microstrategy
what is gonna happen there well they
just came out and publicly said it they
have a brand new CFO and that new CFO on
Wednesday said its strategy to buy and
hold Bitcoin long term won't change
despite the recent sell-off in the
digital asset as we've heard Warren
Buffett and Charlie Munger say multiple
times before their favorite holding
period is forever and their strategy is
to buy great assets and hold them for
forever and so it seems like Michael
sailor microstrategy they believe that
great asset is Bitcoin and regardless of
whether bitcoin's price is up down or
sideways they're going to continue to
accumulate and they have no plans to
sell this is important because what we
do know is that many of the best
performing stocks over the last 20 years
they were super super volatile something
like Amazon literally went down over 90
one time it's drawn down over 30 percent
year after year after year but yet it
remained one of the best performers and
so that volatility actually was a test
if you were a long-term thinker and you
bought the asset you simply held it
something like a Bill Miller then of
course you did very very well bitcoin's
the exact same thing it's gone down over
50 four times in the last four four
years those who have held through all
that volatility they've done pretty well
so far that doesn't mean that the
history of Bitcoin ends up actually
telling us anything about the future but
what it does tell us is that many of the
same Timeless investing principles that
are applicable to stocks Commodities and
real estate you're just as applicable to
bitcoin as well and so to see Michael
Saylor microstrategy and their new CFO
come out and say we ain't selling in
fact nothing about our strategy is going
to change regardless of bitcoin's price
tells you everything you need to know
about their courage and conviction this
is either the greatest trade on Wall
Street or it's going to be disastrous I
tend to think that history would be very
kind to microstrategy Michael Saylor and
the rest of that business but time will
tell